in 1904 st. Louis hosted an Olympic
marathon for the ages overshadowed by
the neighboring World's Fair the poorly
planned event was reduced to a
lackluster sideshow primed for disaster
during a sweltering 90 degree day the
runners were thrust onto a hellish route
that cut through car traffic rocks thick
dust and 300-foot hills of the 32
athletes who competed only 14 finished
and of the 14 these are the three worth
knowing about
Fred lorz was a fresh-faced athlete
ready to make a name for himself for
nine miles lures was near the front of
the pack
until painful muscle cramps stopped him
in his tracks Yanks and he wasn't the
only one almost every single racer had
severe muscle cramps that day thanks to
this dummy chief event organizer and
amateur scientist James Sullivan UC
Sullivan turned the event into an
experiment to grasp how purposeful
dehydration affects athletes immune to
common sense
Sullivan put a single water station at
the 11th mile mark so for 26 miles
the runners relied on one water station
that was dirty and gave you dysentery
James Sullivan what a guy
boobs anyway back to lures with the Sun
beating down road dusk clogging his
lungs and his muscles spazzing in
protest
Laura's had enough and traded in his two
legs for four wheels he hitched a car
ride to the 19th mile mark got out and
gingerly ran through the finish line the
crowd went wild but before the gold
medal could be placed around his neck
his bruise was discovered next up and
the ring carbajal
he was a 5-foot tall Cuban national and
former mailman turned athlete to get to
st. Louis Carbajal had to raise money by
competing and running events including a
700 mile race across Cuba once he got to
st. Louis he was easy to spot among the
sleeveless shirts and thigh-highs shorts
Carbajal wore a billowing long-sleeve
shirt cut off slacks and work boots he
didn't dress like a sports champion but
damn did he run like one
[Music]
with each and every step carbajal
charged towards the finish line
even though his legs never gave out his
grumbling stomach did to satisfy his
hunger he ate some apples from a nearby
orchard that turned out to be rotten so
he took a little recovery nap and then
proceeded to finish in fourth place and
then there's Thomas Hicks the gold
winner the top dog the champion the
barely standing living cadaver you see
Hicks was so physically ill and he
couldn't cross the finish line without
the help of his trainers why well back
then stimulants were legal and
strychnine a type of rat poison was
thought to have performance-enhancing
properties so during the run his
trainers gave him small doses to gain an
edge but instead of helping him it was
slowly killing him once Hicks was
dragged across the finish line he wasn't
in a cheery mood having lost 8 pounds
during the race he was a hollowed-out
husk of a man the judges shrugged he
gave Hicks the gold ending the nightmare
as the crowd swooned over Hicks
disheveled body somewhere in the stands
James Sullivan was probably sipping on a
glass of fresh water feeling proud of
putting together the worst marathon ever
you
[Music]
you